so Bill we've just come off your own
show how do you feel when you come off
doing a show well we just came off yeah
there you go the audience is gone the
question is how did we come off
um the audience is gone and it's just us
it's so intimate Pierce
um you know it's so funny
I don't sleep well on Friday night
because I'm a perfectionist and I'm
always turning the show over in my mind
all night long you know it's a live well
actually we were alive for 20 years I
think the last year since the pandemic
we tape a little earlier but we tape in
time we don't edit anything so it's
basically what happens what is what
happens and so there's always uh you
know expressed Excel yeah as the French
say the thought youth had on the stairs
that oh I should have said that or I
shouldn't have said that or I could have
put that better you know so uh it can go
99 perfectly and I will obsess on the
one percent
I have a an ongoing theory that the
world has gone nuts but what I can't
work out is whether it's just because
we're aware of more stuff which is nuts
than we ever used to be or do you
actually feel oh yeah that it is going
nuts yes absolutely it is going nuts I
mean we sort of touched it on the show
tonight when I was talking about norms
and the attitude I think of the
conservative people in this country
about
what's what disturbs them on the left I
would think it's I would say it's The
Fringe of the left but you know the
problem with the left is that the people
in the center who don't even believe
what The Fringe are believing don't
stand up to them they don't shout them
down publicly so it just becomes it's
very bad for Democrats which I don't
think is a good thing I mostly vote for
Democrats I can't remember the last time
I voted for a republican but
um
the Norms that Trump trounced on
that's a very valid point one I've made
a million times and we all saw it in
plain sight I mean Norms of the law and
democracy and answering subpoenas and
respecting elections and not trying to
have a coup in America I mean it went
past Norms but their view is okay those
are terrible Norms perhaps to trample
but your Norms have to do with like life
itself right biological sex that's
exactly I had that debate tonight yeah
he's kind of baffling to me or actually
having to debate that's that is what
they're saying I've heard I've talked
I've talked to these people all the time
but because I'm out in the country all
the time and they're like you know we're
not all crazy we just don't we just
don't feel comfortable and I've said
this before I'll say it again a lot of
them say to me
what you don't get about us and Donald
Trump is we don't like him either we
just see him as a bulwark toward against
something that's even nuttier because as
we know in America people really don't
vote for who they like they vote for who
they hate the least right
um and where are you with free speech
now because it seems to me that as a
comedian and a host
comedy has never been under more attack
than it is now I mean literally physical
attacks yeah on comedians on stage to
try and suppress their right to tell
jokes what do you feel about that I
think that's exactly I never feel like
I'm about to be attacked on stage it
could happen tomorrow you know
um but I I that's not something that I
there's been a few instances the Dave
Chappelle won obviously the Will Smith I
mean these are outliers we're not really
attacked what we comedians are afraid of
is not being attacked physically on
stage we're afraid of being attacked on
Twitter being canceled yes that I mean I
grew up in the age of the comedy club
and there's comedy clubs are still out
there by the way but you could they were
a place as they say to be bad or a place
even if you weren't bad if you had
passed that point to try out new
materials have we lost the ability as a
society to accept being offended well of
course and that's part of it I mean
comedy has to find where the line is you
know oh you crossed the line well I'm
the guy who's I'm the like the the Mind
Seeker I'm out there with the bayonet
you know digging into the ground to see
where the minds are who decides once in
a while one's going to blow up in our
face some credit for being the guy out
there with the bayonet and who decides
the line
it apparently teenagers who decide
everything in this country because I
feel like teenagers are the ones or
people with a teenage mentality uh who
are are the ones who fill social media
with condemnation because they were
raised wrong
with a sense of entitlement in a sense
that anything that causes the least
amount of discomfort cannot be tolerated
for even one second so when they scream
and cry nobody says anything that's my
point about where are the people to push
back what are the adults I don't think
most I don't think most of the Democrats
or most of the Liberals in this country
old school liberals like me are like
this kind of stuff but they don't shout
it down so if somebody does something
that's a little bit outside the lines
and there is a big complaint on social
media nobody stands up for them and the
problem is that nobody ever gets
canceled through being too woke so you
can say the craziest thing like men can
have babies
and then nobody even though people are
thinking well that's kind of nuts nobody
will say it they'll just fall in line uh
yeah yeah exactly that's what I've
always thought mental babies sure I saw
a dude who was glowing yesterday you
know I mean it's and that's the problem
and it's totally insane cowardice yes it
is it's moral cowardice isn't it but
it's an intellectual characters and but
it also comes from a place of reality
that fear because they see people around
them literally getting canceled getting
shamed and abused and hounded out of
jobs and they think I don't want it to
happen to me it's a very real thing it's
I mean I can't count the number of
stories I've either covered on the show
or just read about of professors at
colleges which are supposed to be the
bastions of free speech who said
something that was just an opinion one
guy that was different from America he
gave a lecture for 25 years about the
use of offensive language and then some
students complained about his use of
offensive language in the lecture about
offensive language and he had to lose
his job and at that point I just felt
that was Peak woke Insanity he literally
was lecturing about offensive language
and using offensive language to
illustrate it they have no sense of
nuance they have no sense of context
they just know certain buzzwords where
certain concepts are out of limits off
limits and since social media is just a
bunch of Mean Girls It's not really
about making the world better it's not
really very often about social justice
it's about let's catch somebody at
something this is what's so obnoxious
about that side of things that just idea
of we're not really lifting people up
liberalism is about lifting people up
not catching and tolerating people it's
not about white self-loathing yes it's
about yes we have a horrible history in
this country let's make it right in the
ways that make sense it's not just about
catching people at stuff
where is America politically now do you
think
I think old school liberalism is the
center
certainly socially you know when I think
about things like pot legalization civil
rights
gay marriage that kind of stuff I mean
something like something over 90 percent
I think of white Americans want to live
in a diverse neighborhood this is a sea
change from the way the where the world
is was when I was born
um gay marriage failed I think 35 times
in different states when it was on the
ballot on a Statewide level and as
something like four years later it was
the law of the land marijuana I never
thought I would see the day where I I
wasn't panicked when I was in an airport
because I had this much pot hidden in my
underwear
and now I can smoke it freely on my
podcast which is why not yes I came out
having had a great time bill
um so I I think that really is kind of
the center of the country old school
liberalism take a Victory lap you kind
of won on a lot of things but it's a
that's another funny pathology of
liberals they don't want to acknowledge
progress because they somehow feel like
if I acknowledge progress well then I'm
not as authentic a progressive it's
right in your name and that's what
you're selling progress well of course
on Donald Trump
all this legal Mayhem that's flying at
him does it actually Empower him does it
have the opposite effect perhaps to what
the Democrats would hope it would have
yes well that was the end of the show
tonight when I was talking about the
Stormy Daniels issue I mean it's always
going to strike people as sex when it's
about getting a guy for sex I don't
think they should ever they should have
discouraged I guess Alvin Bray can do
what he wants but if I was the president
or somebody I would have discouraged him
quietly let's not do this one because
you you're gonna we're gonna see Trump
hauled into court as we did and that's
going to be the big story and it's going
to be just high fives on MSNBC and look
I was thrilled it there's something
cathartic about seeing that because this
guy has done so much damage to this
country as well as so many individuals
so to see him hold into court feels good
but now when these real cases come up
the ones about asking for votes in
Georgia January 6th
um even the documents one I mean I just
think it the the power of it is going to
be diminished we're it's like we've seen
this movie before oh you're always
trying to get them can you win again he
can I don't think he will but it doesn't
matter with him this is the point I've
been making since 2016. well you
predicted I did you said every year I
watched you and you'd say almost
everything he wouldn't accept it he will
never accept it and he didn't and the
problem with next time is he's done this
once and he saw what didn't work the
first time he has been working behind
the scenes to make sure that doesn't
happen again in other words next time he
calls up a republican Secretary of State
and says I need you to find 11 000 votes
is that Republican Secretary of State
going to be somebody who's there who
wasn't in 2016 who is there specifically
to do that so you know I I don't know
what's going to happen in 2024 my my
pretty addiction would be it's Biden
against him again Biden wins again and
he doesn't accept it again is he I mean
is he I'll have to ask about buying
because I've heard you defend him about
his record in the the term I think it's
been actually better than people think
which is why I did better in the
midterms Than People expected but he's
really showing his ages two more years
before an election if he then does four
more he'd be 86. what you know does that
matter it doesn't matter to me I feel
like this is a Prejudice that this
country has this ageism it's a it's an
individual thing age some people are old
at 50. and some people are Young At 90.
Norman lears over a hundred I had dinner
with him recently with other people he
was as sharp as anybody at the table so
it doesn't matter and a president
doesn't have to be super energetic to
run for president takes a lot about it
to be president you're the Elder every
civilization seems to understood this
the Elder we go to you for advice and
wisdom hey Elder one who has seen it all
well he actually bought what should we
do about this problem and then he has
his minions go out and you don't have to
be and also I just think it's a
narrative that oh he looks old he's he
looks like the same guy I've ever seen
he's a little older so he fell off his
bike and you mentioned Trump's fat ass
even being a bike
really Biden did say an odd an
interesting thing actually
he said that yes he's got more
experience than anyone that's ever
become president and he said but that
gives me no excuses gives him the wisdom
but also no excuses I thought I was
quite an honest appraisal of what all
that experience gives him yeah I just
think people have like do I love
everything Biden has done no I don't I
think he caves into that super left side
a little too much I think they go to him
with that stuff and he goes I don't
understand it I can't be bothered with
it I have real matters to do if you want
to do this fine I'm not going to fight
you on it and you know is it as uh
existentially threatening as what Trump
is threatening of course not so but
generally he's doing fine and he's got a
lot more done substantially
legislatively I mean he got us out of
Afghanistan which yeah did he stick the
landing on it no but a lot of that was
because Trump organized that before he
even got there with his stupid will get
out by this date and he only left 2500
troops there he left him a horrible hand
so it's not a terrible idea to say that
and of course the Democrats never do
because they're just so afraid oh
they'll just say we're using excuses
it's a reasonable excuse It's a real
excuse having said that they could have
done it better but at least we did it
and we should have done it and he
actually got the ball rolling on climate
change in a big way that nobody's been
able to do before he steered most of
this big money we're spending towards
stuff they're all really climate change
bills and nobody did that and he got
infrastructure going and you know he's
he's an old school kind of guy is he
perfect of course not but he's getting
the job done and we're back to normal
it's not Insanity he's not you know poop
tweeting and having feuds with Bette
Midler and you know throwing towels at
people I mean it's just it's a lot who's
been for you the greatest American
president them all well certainly the
one I've seen in my lifetime I mean it
would be Obama I mean I didn't see
George Washington but you know he's
still the greatest in my view because
there would be no country without him
and he made some incredible decisions
like how he won the war which most
generals could not have won that war
um and
saying he would not be a king refusing
the crown and saying no we have to have
a peaceful transfer of power I do think
you giving up
while King was a massive strategic error
I'm sure you just for the record
um but Obama you know as far as modern
presidents and no one can compare first
of all because what he did he came in
right at a moment of incredible economic
crisis that a lot of other guys would
have crashed we would be we'd be in a
depression now
and you know no drama Obama boy you know
he just kept it his eye on the ball and
by the way we didn't even lose money we
got all that money paid back you know
Mitt Romney was saying let GM fail and
you know there were some really bad
ideas going around
the first president right that was the
hardest thing I mean I always said and
he had to be the Jackie Robinson of
anyway Jackie Robinson in the sense of
you can't take the bait they're going to
say horrible things you just got to keep
your eye on the ball amazing discipline
this guy has I agree with that does seem
Can Dream still exist
do you think
yeah in fact that's maybe the one thing
that does exist that we still have going
for us because we've lost so much but I
talked about this all the time
um
especially with people who have come to
this country on purpose you know and not
from countries that uh are places you'd
think where people would want to leave
like your country people come here on
purpose I know people from France in
Germany and Canada and I think what they
would say is yes America has a great
flaw in that we don't take care of the
losers quite as well as socialist
countries you know if you fall behind
it's kind of like well see you wouldn't
want to be a
where other countries maybe have a
better social safety net although we do
have a substantial one but what America
does have is still the sense of
possibility you absolutely can't
reinvent yourself tomorrow
and be whatever you want you can make
your future here you can make your way
and you can go as high as as high as you
can they don't cut down the tall trees
as a Canadian friend of mine once said
so in that sense there is still the
American dream now how available is that
to everybody
that's a good question
the correlation is coming up and I know
you're probably trying to suppress your
wild excitement okay will you be
watching no
of course not it's not my country and if
you care about the royal family of
course not it's an inaccuritism and it's
I I said there's two people who are
Royals to their face I'm not going to
call you your highness who did you say
that to I said that to Queen Noor really
absolutely I said it's ridiculous that
one human being this is something
liberals especially should believe
that you don't call another human being
your highness are you kidding me
no and uh you know although I do
personally I like Charles I always
thought he was a smart guy he had some
really good issues you know I thought
they made fun of him you know he had
gave him some ammunition for that but no
public person doesn't but
um you know why why even have this and I
know there are reasons enjoy it whatever
have you been hanging out with Megan and
Harry since they've been in California
no I don't know them
what do you think of them I you know I
said this here I admire Harry for going
to Afghanistan anybody who's had who's
had military service I can only
criticize so much because I haven't and
there's nothing that compares to
military service
um but
they're ridiculous after that they're
just they want it both ways you know you
can't be uh these people were so mean to
us and and poor us and we don't want all
this attention and then let me let me
write a book about how much we don't
want attention a little South Park we
want our privacy yeah I mean sums are
not really they just strike me as
creatures of that generation you know
you're just fragile you know just take a
take a hint from the queen that recently
departed never complained never explain
and rarely be heard speaking in public
you're you're complaining about how your
hard life and you're so privileged it's
just so weird it's ridiculous I totally
agree well you've had an extraordinary
life how long do you think you can keep
doing this decades forever do you think
you'll ever want to stop I have a
contract for a billion years like like
in Scientology I would watch you for it
as long as you want to do it but I I
don't know I mean the fact that I've
done it for 30 years is just ridiculous
but I feel in no way diminished you
enjoy it as much as you've had more
because I'm you know you get better at
what if you do something for 30 years I
mean you better get better you know at a
certain point you know same thing with
Biden
um you know yes age could actually have
an effect on how you're doing but that's
I I would be the first one to tell you
if it did and plainly it's not well the
audience I want you every week and I
have to say I think right now you are
probably the most important I can tell
me because you are the voice of Common
Sense yeah amid all the insanity and
also basically you're on their side
they're loose it's like come on stop
being so mad no I think you're a great
voice too and also of Common Sense and
there's lots of it and by the way none
of us are what anyone 10 years ago would
even begin to call a conservative no you
know Sam Harris is not a conservative
they just these people Barry White not a
concern or not conservatives I mean you
go down the line about what we believe
and how we live our life it's not we're
not out there shooting Bud Lights
but if you're not completely over there
on this side with these people and I
will not bend the knee and just go along
with the nonsense that's what's so
annoying about them the most well they
like insist that you go along with their
nonsense and their insanity and their
fragility or else you're you're you're
thrown outside the group and and you're
excommunicated from liberal and no
you're not the liberal I'm I haven't
changed you invented a whole new thing
called wokism which used to have a much
more valid meaning you know alert to
Injustice great who's not for that and
then it became all these things which
are not building on liberalism they're
very often the opposite of liberalism
you know liberalism was it's actually a
form of fascism the way they go about it
the way they without the extreme
violence but the ideology that you will
conform yes to our narrow worldview and
if you don't we're going to really do
bad stuff to you yeah that's a fascist
mentality it's it's it's the cry bullies
of that generation as I said raised
wrong
so they think when someone disagrees
with them it's a hate crime and it's
violence and it's unacceptable and it's
just got to stop you don't get your
teenagers under control yeah that's my
message Bill it's a great message keep
battling I'm with you thank you on the
hill all right